we're gonna talk about that parallel
economy Bill Gates bets on bud light's
comeback as Tech Mogul buys 1.7 million
shares of disgraced Brands parent
company it's so serious that the Daily
Mail put Three L's in million uh after
the Dylan Mulvaney partnership
the Microsoft founder acquired the Bud
Light shares via his Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation trust during the second
quarter of this year the shares hold a
market value of approximately 95 million
dollars reports tip ranks
my friends
we stand before us a great opportunity
if we
convince everyone not to drink Bud Light
and double down on the boycott not only
will you teach a woke Corporation a
lesson a corporation that keeps doubling
down on this messaging despite the
backlash you will drive
you will you will take money away from
Bill Gates
the shares that he purchased will go
down in value and he will lose money
grant that's only 95 million dollars you
know and if this drops back a couple
bucks he's going to go down to like 90
he's not really going to Blink the dudes
worth 100 plus billion dollars but uh
you know whatever one can dream it's a
victory for you not for not a loss for
him
but this is this is it you know
obviously I'm not surprised to see this
from Bill Gates this to me seems more
like Bill Gates is trying to save the
stock price of Anheuser-Busch yeah this
purchase is going to stabilize the price
to a certain degree or perhaps even
create the perception it's recovering in
an attempt to manipulate people who
don't care about the culture wars into
buying the stocks again or the shares
and then that will cause more people to
want to be involved
I say
don't let them do it
don't let them do it I'm not I'm not
gonna give you Financial advice I'm just
saying from a culture cultural
perspective we have to double down on
the on the Bud Light story once again
the fact that Bill Gates just bought a
large portion of it is all the more
reason to absolutely reject Bud Light as
a product
what percentage did he get out of that
oh it's microscopic in terms of
anheuser's you know
what is it they say Bud Light shares
that's probably you know a b inbev
stock prices drop it shares an inbev not
necessarily in in Bud Light or in uh
Budweiser yeah they say Bud Light stock
but I'm pretty sure that it's actually
shares an anhyzer which is a b inbev
yeah I mean I don't think we have
anything to worry about a lot of people
are still not buying but like yeah Bud
Light to hire the Dasani guy because
nobody buys Dasani water then we just
get them to lose money you buy Dasani
water yes we found the one person I love
this have you ever seen those pictures
like Florida in after a hurricane like
all the water's gone except for the
Dasani Waters all just sitting there
you're the one guy yeah well they like I
love stuff
I like designing and I like Aquafina I
bought both of them I buy one pack of
Dasani one pack Aquafina well let's
let's talk about this parallel economy
right so outside of what you know Bill
Gates may want to do you've got
conservative dad's Ultra right beer uh
this is uh Southwest we've got a bunch
of the his beer we ordered it it's it's
it's good stuff and uh they're doing
sales by the by the truckload it's crazy
apparently they're doing ridiculously
well
you take a look at the failures of these
companies when they get woke and go
broke and uh on in this story we have
the Amazing Story of a young man who had
one dream and now to sell pancakes
before that was my American Dream all I
ever wanted was freedom and pancakes so
uh let's let's talk about your pancakes
though because this is a big component
of building this parallel economy I want
to say
I was personally deeply offended when
they took Aunt Jemima away because when
I was little we had Aunt Jemima all the
time I'd go downstairs I'd grab the box
I I would never follow the instructions
I would just pour the mix into the into
the cup I'd mix it with a little bit of
milk or something and then just throw in
the pan with too much butter so it got
fried and you know ridiculous and
delicious and then I grew up on that and
like we're not racist my family we we
liked the brand it was we had Aunt
Jemima syrup and then one day they
decided it was not okay for for people
for anybody to smile and look up to an
iconic figure on a product that was
black Uncle Ben Aunt Jemima and and Mrs
Butterworth they took anyone who was
black off of products they're the Lakes
ladies there was a guy on Cream of Wheat
too it's a black guy on the cream of
wheat that was good they took him off
the Box they took him off of his product
also what what is that guy's name on the
cream of wheat I think it was awesome
yeah white yeah they took this guy off
the box also that that but but like I
said earlier it's insane because these
same people who were upset that a black
face was on a food box are the same
people who say black people need more
representation but if you go into the
grocery store now you don't see any
black people on any food boxes at all
you got Chef Boyardee yeah he's still
there the Quaker Oats guy he's still
there Quaker Oats is Happy s he's
happier he is happy as hell and he is
happy as hell he's like hell yeah that's
a religious thing too he's a Quaker yeah
this is what bothered me is that like
imagine you go to a restaurant every day
and
there like you go to you go for
breakfast before work and there's Aunt
Jemima making your pancake smiling she's
a good friend she's always there you
know that when you're having a rough day
you show up and she's got a smile on her
face and delicious pancakes and then one
day the boss is like we got rid of her
because we have a black person working
here it's racist that's basically what
they did to the exactly what it is of
these characters I I just not like like
who like how were you sleep at night
because this black woman was on a
pancake box like who was sitting up at
night uh rolling over in bed can't sleep
and they uh oh this is like that's
bothering you check it out the family
got mad yes because they were getting
paid I guess oh no multiple because
multiple women have portrayed onto my
man in history and that's it this is
yeah this is the craziest thing I heard
they said
so they're claiming that Aunt jemama is
like some slave figure and they're
saying that white people get a kick out
of this black woman making them pancakes
it's like she's like a house slave in
the home of like in in in the home of
white people so they really didn't want
white people uh having this black
character on a food box in their cabinet
it's this was she a slave no she was not
a slave but they said she's a
spokesperson but they're saying that she
is like a slave figure like a like like
a house slave so that's what they were
trying to claim but it's ridiculous I
have not met one person who wanted this
woman off of the box I want to meet the
people yeah I want to meet these people
I want to meet your mama herself and
then you went and put yourself on then
exactly and listen like on your mama any
time that I had Aunt Jemima I was I mean
extremely happy and you know and I was
introduced to Aunt Jemima when I was
growing up when I was growing up in uh
foster care one of my foster homes all
they bought was Aunt Jemima uh pancakes
so I was introduced to her and I just
fell in love with that mix 6. so and
every time I see that box it brings back
memories from childhood and then they
took it away so I was like what the like
what in the hell you should see if the
company will sell it will sell you the
trademark the thing about it they would
never do that they would no but they've
abandoned it you might be able to just
take it that's like like you were
talking about it's a logo for
Independence yeah no because no they are
still using it if you now they're not
using her face but they're using the
name on the new box it's Pearl Milling
Company no they're used no if you if you
see the box at the very bottom it says
uh uh it says formerly Aunt Jemima
uh uh same taste that's not your mama so
they're still using but they're still
using this wrong man but you still might
have a legal challenge to the trademark
because yeah they've changed it so we
have this right here this is uh Tim cast
skateboard company which I announced
several months ago and and independent
has no challenge this symbol right here
is is uh it used to be the independent
skateboard trucks logo and they
abandoned it because people said it
looks like a German Iron Cross or
something and it's it's racist or
whatever so they apologize no we're not
racist they got rid of that logo
and so I said okay then it's a it's
abandoned IP it's now public domain I'm
using it
so I could try I could try and you know
one thing that all Americans most of us
have in common white white people black
people Hispanics all Americans most
Americans love pancakes and if they
don't love pancakes they love waffles
you know and and that's one thing that
will bring people together is food
pancakes waffles or french toast
pancakes pancakes pancakes you use
different kinds of flour uh do I use
different almond flour do you ever no I
I do not have almond flour but I am
coming out with a with a vegan mix how's
that work how's what's the ingredients
no buttermilk it's gonna be but like a
vanilla bean
um and then I have a keto mix that'll
come out soon and also I have
gluten-free at the moment what's the
gluten-free the gluten-free how do you
make it yeah uh man it's so many
different ingredients but yeah I I need
to read all the ingredients yeah yeah
flowers yeah
um
but it's uh and then then I have like
different flavors I have uh uh you know
like blueberry apple cinnamon cinnamon
bun oh wow
um chocolate chip you know and yeah oh
what was the other one chocolate chip uh
yeah so I have chocolate chip and uh
sweet potato mix pumpkin spice I have a
whole bunch of different mixes but I
need to find out you know the
gluten-free stuff is gluten-free
certified so anything I say on here I
have to get it right yeah they'll be
breathing down my back freeze where it's
at yeah sometimes but look at how I feel
about that pumpkin spice one but the
rest of it you know you're you're in uh
what do you say 38 stores yeah so I'm in
yes I'm in the Sedano Supermarket it's
in South Florida how do we get cousin
T's so you wide in every Supermarket oh
man getting these so so many so many of
the grocery stores are so woke and you
know and this is the tough thing here so
you know cousin T's now people can get
it on cousin tees.com right now
um uh so I ship everywhere but you know
I'm still I'm a small business and uh
what it cost me to make my pancake mix
the big brands are selling it for what I
for what like there's the the price that
they're selling it at is a price that
I'm buying it at because they buy
millions of boxes to drive their costs
down I don't have the money to do that
right so in the grocery stores they like
to mark up the products 30 to 40 percent
well my product is already it it's all
right it's it's already expensive yeah
compared to and it's a gourmet product
too so it is more expensive compared to
the bigger Brands
um so you know if you put my stuff on
the Shelf it's going to be way more
expensive because the grocery stores
market up 30 or 40. so that's so that's
so so that's what I'm dealing with too
and all also Walmart is so woke Target
is woke and they like I said anytime I
try to get into these stores they they
go they most likely they look at my
social media account they say no we
can't take it they don't return my
emails
calling them racist
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time